[Music]
surviving in venezuela has been a
challenge for maria jelitsa vergara
she received a kidney transplant 17
years ago
but last year her kidneys began to fail
again
and like thousands of other high-risk
patients in the country
she's hoping to get her second covid19
vaccine dose
soon it's been a week since i was
supposed to get my second dose
i have no clue what's going on i don't
know why they didn't do everything right
why can't they do it right for once the
same thing with transplants
four years without a transplant all
patients like me are in the hands of god
i need forty two dollars to pay for
medications and my pension is one dollar
and i need to have two jobs venezuela is
struggling with u.s sanctions
and an economic crisis that is impacting
its ability to fight against the disease
the south american nation is part of the
kovac system
which is a collaborative effort designed
to help countries like venezuela
get access to vaccines but that's proven
to be a challenge
so far it has only received around 3.5
million doses from china and russia
and the country is currently testing
thousands of doses of vaccines from cuba
two months ago kovacs announced payments
made to the system by venezuela had been
blocked by the swiss bank ubs
even though the biden administration
said all related covet purchases were
exempted from the sanctions
on sunday president nicolas maduro said
the kovac system has failed venezuela
we fulfilled our promises two months ago
we gave them all our money by doing
magic to liberate funds that were
blocked
the government of the united states then
unblocked more money for us
and that money is there in an account
and the kovacs has failed the people of
venezuela
either you give us the vaccines or
return our money
earlier this year venezuela rejected
around 2 million astrazeneca vaccines
from kovacs
due to safety concerns but opposition
figures say
venezuela could be accessing vaccines
for free
miguel pizarro who is currently on exile
say
the reasons why we don't have access to
free vaccines like countries like syria
sudan or yemen countries that have
humanitarian emergencies that are
acknowledged by the united nations
the reason is the obscurity of
statistics of numbers
in front of the world bank are numbers
that show when venezuela enjoyed an oil
bonanza
and that's not the case anymore
as politicians baker over who is to
blame for the hardships in the country
millions of venezuelans are impatiently
waiting for an opportunity to get the
vaccine
people like maria jeriza vergara
struggling with a life-threatening
disease says
it's her only chance of surviving covet
19.
terisa